bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 26 avril jour après jour l'exode
des albanais du kosovo vers la macédoine
l'albanie via le monténégro apporte son
lot de misères et de désespérance les
pays d'accueil font ce qu'ils peuvent le
président de l'albanie est en france
nous l'entendons nous irons à shkodra en
albanie avec aubry et de l'air puis de
l'autre côté de la frontière au
monténégro avec benoît dickens pour
constater cet exode
nous serons dans la zone albanaise de
coût cash avec l'autre sans père et
tandis que la croix-rouge développe son
action à belgrade le président de la
cicr le comité international de la
croix-rouge a rencontré scott dann
milosevic monsieur ce maroga le
président du cicr sera notre invité en
direct de zagreb dans quelques instants
la capitale de la croatie dans
l'actualité également la corse avec le
placement en garde à vue d'un colonel de
gendarmerie dans une enquête sur
l'incendié de paillote de plage pas
d'ajaccio
et puis en angleterre le roi c'est gino
là le footballeur david ginola sacré
meilleur joueur de l'année
david ginola sera en direct avec nous
dans la dernière partie de ce journal au
600 milles albanais du kosovo réfugiés
dans les pays limitrophes il faut
maintenant ajouter des milliers d'autres
venus de la région de pêche
après avoir traversé le monténégro pour
rejoindre la ville frontière albanaise
de shkodra ils sont entassés dans les
locaux d'anciennes usines démunies et
sans réelle assistance humanitaire
extérieure
voyez le reportage d'aubry et de l'air
et patrick joye
quand on découvre l'endroit on a
l'impression d'une prison d'un autre âge
dans cette usine de tabac parce qu en
ruine 5 ou 6000 personnes
les estimations sont devenus difficiles
ont fini par trouver un refuge
dans la cour des plus vaillants tourner
en rond pour tromper l'attenté d'une
solution qui paraît bien improbable ici
on se presse à l'unique point d'eau qui
déclarait potable sert à tout dans ce
camp improvisé
à l'intérieur il semble temps assez
pêle-mêle leur arrivée massive au fil
des huit derniers jours les stars
gouvernement albanais bien dépourvu le
soin de gérer la pénurie un peu de pain
et de fromage composent les rations
quotidiennes
tout ça est imprévu s'attendait pas à st
tout ce monde nous ne veut rien faire de
plus le problème c'est que les ong sont
lentes arrivée la situation ne peut
qu'empirer épuisé déjà terrorisée par
l'exil forcé ils ont tous fui le
monténégro craignant les représailles de
l'armée serbe
mais ces kosovars ne se plaignent pas
nous accueillant parfois même avec la
dignité imposant de ceux qui après avoir
tout perdu conserve un espoir intacte
sur la route on a vu des soldats serbes
ça a été la panique mais on va gagner
nous reviendrons au kosovo
quand on pense à ce qu'on vit à ce qu'on
a déjà vécu on ne peut que devenir fou
faute de place dans la région rien ne
semble encore prévues pour évacuer vers
un camp plus digne ces milliers de
laissés pour compte
le hcr n'a pas encore réussi à susciter
la générosité de propriétaires peu
désireuse de prêter leur terrain pour
raisons humanitaires
alors que l'affluence semble s'apaiser
du côté de cook s7 au rythme de deux
mille réfugiés par jour qu'un autre
front du malheur s'ouvre à la frontière
du monténégro les kosovars représente
désormais près de 20 % d'une population
albanaise elles mêmes contraintes à la
misère alors en un monde de cette ville
de shkodra dans les montagnes
frontalières du monténégro entre armées
serbes et police fidèle ou gouvernement
monténégrins de podgorica la capitale
les colonnes de réfugiés sont soumises
aux ordres et contre-ordres reportage
benoît duquesne jean françois rault nous
c'est une journée de pluie au camp de
rejaillir une journée de plus aux portes
du kosovo à la fois si près si loin de
ce qui faisait leur vie de leurs maisons
de leurs fermes de leurs terres il y a
maintenant des jours que les réfugiés ne
passe plus par les montagnes pour
arriver ici la frontière a été bouclé
par la deuxième armée serbe
le flot s'est tari pourtant les bonnes
nouvelles existent quand même dans cette
boue et sous cette pluie on nous
présente cet homme arrivé la veille avec
quelques autres pendant sa fuite il
avait été séparé de sa femme et de ses
deux filles emmenées par les milices
paramilitaires battu il a été relâché
après une semaine de captivité
on a roulé un jour et une nuit dans un
camion militaire on ne sait pas où on
allait et puis ils nous ont retenus dans
un lieu pendant ces jours là on a dû
répondre à toutes leurs questions
il voulait savoir si on ne faisait pas
partie de l'ue ces cas si on n'était pas
des terroristes
et puis nous ont lâchés et c'est là
qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'on était en
fait en serbie dans le camp la vie s'est
organisée tant bien que mal mais les
chances ici comme ailleurs ne sont pas
les mêmes pour tous selon sa date
d'arrivée
l'organisme humanitaire qui vous a pris
en charge et surtout selon ses moyens
la plupart de ceux qui avaient de
l'argent pour se payer le voyage sont
partis plus au sud
les autres attendent au rythme des
soupes et des distributions de pain
quand elles sont faites cette femme par
exemple avec ses neuf enfants nous dira
ne pas avoir reçu de pain depuis trois
jours un peu plus chanceux ceux qui ont
été hébergés dans ses usines
ils y sont au sec la distribution de
nourriture est plus régulière il y a une
antenne médicale et même quelques
douches que l'on installe ils y sont à
l'abri mais presque prisonniers sortir
l'orée des conseillers c'est vrai qu'on
était en sécurité
mais on voit que l'armée serbe n'est pas
loin d'ici elle est tout autour de la
ville
il n'y a pas longtemps l'armée et les
milices sont à frapper des hommes dans
le village de draguer tout près d'ici
ils les ont roués de coups et l'or ont
cassé les côtes
c'est bien ce genre d'incident que
craignent les autorités locales cette
cohabitation impossible entre une armée
une population pro-serbe autour de la
ville et cette enclave musulmane
nous sommes à la frontière du kosovo est
donc toute déstabilisation ici peut très
bien se propager à l'ensemble du
monténégro
c'est ce qu'on craint avec les réfugiés
c'est pour ça en plus des raisons
humanitaires
on les incite à partir vers le sud et en
l'espace de quelques jours au rythme de
20 ou 30 bus par jour
rosa y est a perdu la moitié de ces
réfugiés alors benoît est ce qu'on peut
y voir un peu plus clair sur ce qui se
passe à la frontière associer la police
du monténégro l'armée serbe qui a le pas
sur notre est ce qu'il ya un semblant de
partage du pouvoir mais côté je
comprends pas très bien mais ce qui se
passe à la frontière c'est un petit peu
en fait
à l'image de ce qui se passe dans ce
pays et c'est à dire d'un compromis
permanent entre le pouvoir monténégrins
qui tient à sa ligne d'autonomie vont
pas lire la dépendance et puis l'armée
fédérale elle qui représente belgrade ce
qui fait que à la frontière là pour
aller dans cette ville est bien ma foi
la route et est relativement sûr il n'y
a pas de problème on rencontre assez peu
de militaires n'y a pas de barrage sur
la route si vous voulez en revanche la
police dès la sortie de la ville nous
explique qu'il faut pas du tout
continuer plus loin puisque après c'est
l'armée qui a le pouvoir entre
guillemets et c'est un petit peu la même
chose que ce qui se passe dans tous les
domaines de la vie on l'a vu avec par
exemple embargo pétrolier
on a vu que d'un côté le premier
ministre dit ne nous sanctionner pas
avec un embargo on vous assure que le
pétrole ici de servira qu'aux civils et
ce matin le le général en chef de la
deuxième armée serbe est bien dit le
pétrole nous réquisitionnerons nous pour
l'armée c'est la même chose encore pour
la presse par exemple le ministère de
l'information certifie que les juristes
peuvent travailler comme ils le veulent
et font tout leur possible pour qu'ils
puissent rentrer dans le pays et puis en
même temps et bien on les jours ils sont
souvent arrêtés ennuyé par l'armée quand
ce n'est pas plus grave la même façon la
presse indépendante ici essaye aussi de
travailler est l'un des principaux
leaders cette presse-là a fait savoir
hier par exemple que eh bien il préféré
se retirer dans la clandestinité parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas sûrs de pouvoir
continuer à le faire à cause des
pressions de l'armée dont c'est un
fragile équilibre et le pouvoir étant
amenés à multiplier si vous voulez les
genres de concessions ben on a juste une
précision sur l'état sanitaire des
réfugiés que vous avez montré dans votre
reportage et qui a présence de médecins
d'organisation qui qui aide les
personnes qui sont manifestement très
fatigué très las mais le travail de ré
so many terre international est pas
facile ici vous en douter puisque nous
trouvons quand même sur le territoire de
la yougoslavie
il ya donc là des gens médecins du monde
les gens médecins sans frontières des
gens du hr mais ils ne peuvent pour la
plupart enfin dans la plupart des cas
elles n'ont pas intervenir directement
ce sont les autorités locales elle qui
interviennent donc il leur est difficile
d'intervenir les gens sont dans des
situations des terres qui ne sont pas
dramatiques n'y a pas péril de vie ou de
mort pour ces gens là mais leurs
situations sont très compliquées les
soutes n'arrive pas le pain c'était le
gros problème à ces jours ci le pain
n'arrivent pas non plus et c'est fait en
fait parce que dans cette région là
particulièrement et bien les autorités
souhaitent qu'une chose c'est que les
réfugiés sans ail parts au sud par
éventuellement en albanie pour diminuer
ce foyer de tensions potentielles
merci benoît
les témoignages des réfugiés font état
de sévices de viols de meurtres certains
évoquent des prises d'otages de femmes
et d'enfants des niveaux d'un immeuble
servant de dépôt de munitions
information qui ne peuvent être
vérifiées dans le nord de l'albanie les
autorités de cook et se déclare prête à
appliquer une loi d'expulsion contre les
albanais du kosovo qui refuseraient de
partir vers le sud
faute de savoir ce qui les attend
reportage côte samper bernie mériaux il
faut repartir chaque jour plusieurs
centaines de réfugiés sont évacués des
camps du nord de l'albanie vers le sud
pour être plus en sécurité le petit camp
de chrome 1 est tout près de la
frontière avec le kosovo
le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
considère ce secteur comme une zone de
guerre et il demande donc aux réfugiés
de reprendre la route
mais aucune évacuation et auquel est de
force
est ce que vous savez madame pourquoi
vous devez partir aujourd'hui des
ignares non non je ne sais pas et les
gens disent c'est dangereux ici il faut
partir et nous en dit allez on y va
les réfugiés qui souhaite rester le
peuvent certains préfèrent continuer à
vivre ici près de leur pays le kosovo et
ne pas aller dans des camps qui me
connaissent pas même si les conditions
de vie sont ici parfois très difficile
ils ne veulent pas repartir
le hcr lui anticipe un nouvel afflux de
réfugiés et préfère garder des places
libres à deux heures de route du petit
camp de chrome à la vie le coût cash au
pied des montagnes qui marque la
frontière avec le kosovo
c'est ici que pour la première fois un
porte-parole de luczak a fait une grande
conférence de presse encadré par une
certaine protection
léopard 2 c'est le seul nom qu'il
acceptera de nous donner a expliqué
durant près d'une heure qu'il voulait
que l'otan donne des armes à l'armée de
libération du kosovo
à lomme un souhaitait également en
engagement rapide des hélicoptères
apache
au même moment le commandant suprême des
forces de l'otan effectué une visite
surprise à coup pêche une visite garder
top secrète jusqu'au dernier moment le
général wesley clark n'a pas répondu
publiquement demande de loups checa le
général a parlé exactement une minute 40
juste pour dire qu'il venait vérifier si
les opérations devaient être menées par
les militaires fonctionnaient
parfaitement bien avec le hcr est selon
lui il n'y a absolument aucun problème
aujourd'hui a coupé ses militaires des
forces alliées continue d'installer une
petite base logistique pour le hcr le
haut commissariat aux réfugiés
seul problème cette base devrait être
terminée dans une dizaine de jours et
hors caméra les responsables du hcr
considère que décidément les militaires
prennent vraiment leur temps l'opération
abri alliés semblent ici connaître un
certain retard alors qu'il ya urgence
le président albanais monsieur mais ce
déni est arrivé ce soir pour une visite
de deux jours en france il rencontrera
demain monsieur jacques chirac et
monsieur lionel jospin l'albanie se
trouve confronté un véritable désarroi
économique compte tenu de la présence de
près de quatre cent mille réfugiés sur
son territoire sur le rôle de l'otan et
les buts de guerre entretien avec
monsieur meziani réalisé par jean-marc
il use avec jacques grigor l'état
albanais aient la volonté du peuple
albanais et que de répondre positivement
à chaque demande de l'otan elle pourrait
être avec l'otan à chaque opération
humanitaire aux militaires à votre avis
est il possible d'envisager une solution
diplomatique du conflit avec le régime
du président milosevic toujours les
solutions diplomatiques et politiques le
sens positif du poids né dans ce cas
milosevic son régime sont allées très
loin avec cette politique de crimes de
génocide de nettoyage ethnique et je
crois que actuellement les pays
démocrates et ils doivent en poser les
conditions
pour faire possible le retour des
albanais déportés chose on a posé c'est
à dire par la force une pause c'est à
dire par tout les moyens la force y
compris y compris par un déploiement
terrestre y compris aussi jagot option
observons maintenant la carte de cette
région du monde on note que la hongrie a
autorisé le teint se servir de ses bases
militaires que la bulgarie autorise un
survol mais la grèce pays membre de
l'otan a toujours fait part de son
opposition en actions engagées
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui encore en début
de soirée plusieurs milliers de
personnes manifestaient contre l'action
de temps et hier ici plusieurs centaines
de grecs participé à une marche
pacifiste de marathon la ville située au
nord d'athènes jusqu'à l'ambassade
américaine où avait lieu un concert
contre l'action de l'otan engagées au
kosovo est un territoire serbe
il faut aussi préciser que la roumanie
est candidate à l'otan tandis que la
macédoine et la croatie ne sont pas sur
la liste des futurs membres potentiels
tandis que l'albanie sert effectivement
de base aux effectifs de l'alliance les
bombardements de l'otan étaient moins
intensifs pour des raisons de météo
défavorable le pont de novi sad auraient
été détruits c'est un pont sur le danube
d'autre part des missiles auraient été
tirés sur des dépôts de carburant selon
des informations données par le temps
informations non vérifiables sur le
terrain au lendemain du sommet de l'otan
à washington il a été précisé que les
bâtiments de guerre en adriatique ne
recourrait pas à la force pour faire
respecter un embargo pétrolier à moscou
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères monsieur gregory b 9 a
souligné que tout embargo pétrolier
devait être soumis à une décision du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu
manifestement gilles rabin moscou il
n'est pas mécontent de l'embarras un
terme constaté washington parmi les pays
de l'alliance
à propos de cet embargo oui tout à fait
tout simplement parce que les russes ont
eu très peur d'avoir à faire face à une
nouvelle escalade qui les aurait de
nouveau laissé sans vraies possibilités
de riposte
vous savez claude les russes pense
toujours qu'une solution passe entre un
compromis entre la yougoslavie et l'otan
compromis forcément improbable qu'ils
ont déjà testé deux fois sans succès sur
deux adversaires également et
transigeant
toute nouvelle escalade tout
renforcement des mesures de l'otan
contre la yougoslavie détruit à l'avance
tout temps tu me chacune de leurs
tentatives de négociations alors malgré
l'échec de la mission de monsieur victor
tchernomirdine qui l'envoyé spécial de
brice et cible les russes continuent
d'être courtisé pour une possible
solution diplomatique
écoutez à moscou on pense qu'une
médiation russe est toujours possible et
peut-être qu'on pense aussi ailleurs à
preuve le secrétaire d'état américain
adjoint sera là demain
kofi annan le secrétaire général des
nations unies sera là jeudi les russes
pensent qu'ils peuvent encore réussir à
trouver une solution au conflit et vous
savez on a eu aujourd'hui quelques
détails sur le plan de composition de la
force internationale de sécurité que
tchernomyrdine aurait négocié jeudi
dernier à belgrade
l'ossature de cette force aurait été
composé de soldats russes et ukrainiens
auxquels se seraient joints des soldats
d'ouzbékistan d'azerbaidjan et de
géorgie
trois ex pays soviétiques mais qui
présente l'avantagé d'être aujourd'hui
plutôt pro occidentaux des soldats
tchèques et des soldats polonais
seraient présents eux aussi
certes ce sont deux piles de république
tchèque et la pologne qui sont de
nouveaux membres de l'otan mais qui
présente l'avantagé de ne pas participer
actuellement à la campagne de
bombardements et qui sont des pays
slaves
alors on ne sait pas si une telle force
qui fait penser un peu à une
résurrection du défunt pacte de 20 de
varsovie serait réaliste et on peut
douter qu'elle soit acceptable pour les
pays de l'otan mais c'est la preuve en
tout cas lundi ce que les russes
cherchent une solution
merci j l'aide humanitaire
internationale venus d'europe et
notamment de la france arrive maintenant
en masse via la croix rouge dans les
camps installés en albanie en macédoine
mais plus compliqué il faut atteindre
les kosovars qui sont logés chez
l'habitant et pour les membres de la
croix-rouge macédonienne la logistique
demande beaucoup de rigueur
reportage pascal d'où ces bons emmanuel
bec
hier les camions ont apporté des vivres
aujourd'hui matelas et couvertures ont
enfin atteint ou pas au à 40km de skopje
mais ne comptez pas sur arsène
arseneault ski pour laisser le désordre
s'installer pour autant le patron de la
croix rouge locale mène son petit monde
à la baguette
il entend bien appliquer à la lettre le
règlement donne moi ta carte verte
sans ce sésame délivré par les autorités
macédoniennes pas de matelas ni de
nourriture
bon ben alors avec la mer ça fait sept
personnes toute la famille est sur la
liste
il faut encore prouvé son passage au
bureau qu'on sache écrire ou non si
arsène ars 9 ce qui est si pointilleux
c'est parce que pour l'instant il ne
peut satisfaire que les deux tiers de la
demande
pas question donc de distribuer sans
être sûr d'avoir affaire à des réfugiés
en ce qui concerne cela aucun doute
possible
ils sont en règle ils peuvent alors
ramené leurs premiers colis depuis
qu'ils sont arrivés du kosovo jusqu'à
présent les camps étaient prioritaires
sur les réfugiés hébergés par l'habitant
et puis les villages sont plus
difficiles à atteindre et bien malin qui
sait exactement combien de réfugiés
hexacore ils sont combien accord dans le
village dans nos villages il faut on a
mené aujourd'hui
un camion des camions avec deux matelas
des couvertures
il y à 84 mille personnes dans cette
même situation au en macédoine
c'est pas évident les branches croix
rouge font de leur mieux mais ils sont
ils ont peu de volontaires peu
d'employés le réseau existe et il faut
il faut les soutenir il faut les aider à
aider à leur tour mais jusqu'où peut
aller cette solidarité albanaise
alors que chaque jour de nouveaux
réfugiés clandestins ou non se font
connu la macédoine n'est pas l'albanie
ici aucune organisation humanitaire ne
se plaint de la disparition de colis en
revanche il est très difficile de savoir
combien de réfugiés non enregistrés sont
encore dans ces villages de montagne et
cela pour l'instant doivent se
débrouiller seul le comité international
de la croix rouge devrait reprendre ses
opérations humanitaires en yougoslavie
monsieur cornelio sommaruga président de
ce comité a rendu visite ce matin en
trois prisonniers américains militaires
capturés le 31 mars par l'armée serbe
puis monsieur ce maawg a rencontré
slobodan milosevic à belgrade qu'on voit
ici sur ces messieurs se marrent au
gabon soir bonjour vous trouvez
actuellement à zagreb en croatie
alors qu'avez vous obtenu de monsieur
milosevic
bon je crois qu'il ya une ouverture
malgré la divergence de appréciation de
la situation à l'intérieur du kosovo une
ouverture pour que le cicr avec ses
délégués puissent opérer au kosovo en
sécurité et aussi selon ses propres
méthodes c'est à dire pour le rejoindre
toutes les personnes pour les protéger
et les assister j'ai du reste remis à
monsieur milosevic
un document qui est une sorte de projet
d'accord qui devra être signée pour
qu'on puisse le plus tôt possible
rejoindre ces personnes car nous sommes
préoccupés pour un nombre de kosovars
qui sont dans les forêts qui sont dans
les montagnes mais actuellement il
faudra aussi l'accord de l'otan pour
pouvoir le faire
mais est-ce à dire que vous allez
organiser une sorte de couloirs
humanitaires avec une protection
deux forces internationales pour ce
couloir humanitaire
non ce n'est pas la façon dont opère le
cicr nous voulons être tout à fait livre
de forces internationales aux forces de
sécurité locales
nous devons pouvoir circuler librement
et il semble que selon les propos du
président milosevic que j'ai rencontrés
pendant presque une heure et demie
aujourd'hui et dont la discussion a été
animée surtout les docteurs il semble
bien qu'il ait l'accord pour pouvoir
opérer comme vous dites discussions
animées et se dire que monsieur
milosevic je reconnais ou ne reconnaît
pas le fait qu'il ya des exactions des
tueries des massacres qui se répéterait
actuellement que ce mot bon ça aurait
été étrange qu'il reconnaisse ce que moi
je lui ai dit entendre notamment après
avoir visité plusieurs camps en albanie
et en macédoine mais il est clair que la
discussion a eu lieu sur ce sujet et que
la problématique des réfugiés a été
abordé directement et il a mentionné son
intérêt à voir le retour de tous les
réfugiés donc une ouverture dans ce sens
mais pour moi ce qui est essentiel pour
le retour c'est d'assister sur la
sécurité de ces personnes
avez vous le sentiment que monsieur
milosevic est prêt à une forme de
négociation
écoutez et 6,7 pour la dépossession
humanitaire je dirais oui parce que il a
déjà négocié avec moi d'un certain
nombre de détails
pour ce qui est de la négociation
politique c'est pas à moi de prendre
position
vous n'étiez pas porteur d'un message de
pays qui sont de l'autre camp du camp de
l'otan et des pays de l'alliance
non c'est pas l'habitude du cicr de
opéré de cette façon ce que nous
voulions obtenir c'était de
l'humanitaire de l'humanitaire comme
priorité pour le kosovo de l'humanitaire
quand même aussi pour les victimes
civiles en yougoslavie où nous sommes
présents avec une délégation de délégués
victime indirecte des bombardements il y
en a il y en a beaucoup surtout si en
france à la ville de novi sad où j'ai
fait une visite hier où les trois grand
pont sur le danube ont été détruits et
dans des ponts il avait les conduites
d'eau et une grande partie de la ville
lorsque vous le regardez c'est presque
90 mille habitants sont restés sans eau
potable
donc il y a des conséquences
humanitaires et il faut que la croix
rouge d'une façon impartiale
puis s'occuper de tout l'éviter mais si
la croix rouge est présente au kosovo
est ce qu'elle ne sera pas accusée
d'être l'allié objectif de l'armée ou
des milices serbes écouter un je ne veux
pas que ans et ainsi lui que la croix
rouge puis s'être allié avec qui que ce
soit notre action est une action
indépendante neutre impartial et elle a
toujours comme objectif de victimes
c'est ce que nous voulons faire partout
en yougoslavie
nous le faisons intensément monténégro
mais maintenant nous allons même
augmenter cette activité nous le faisons
en service mais nous voulons surtout le
faire en kosovo au kosovo parce que nous
savons qu'il ya des grands besoins et
nous le ferons de façon indépendante
nous devons pouvoir le faire d'une façon
indépendante
malheureusement nous l'avons pas encore
fait mais j'espère que ce soit le cas
assez tôt il y à une date prévue cela va
mieux et vite s'est engagé à quelque
chose de précis et il s'est engagé à ce
que nous allions tout de suite moi je ne
veux pas partir avant d'avoir qualifié
sa part écrit sur le projet d'accord que
j'ai mais j'aurai besoin de l'assurance
de toutes les parties en cause et toutes
les parties en cause signifie aussi
l'otan et l'ue ces cas c'est à dire que
vous demanderez à l'otan de ne pas
bombarder certains lieux il ya lucci cas
de ne pas attaquer à dans certains
endroits je demanderai tout simplement à
toutes les parties en conflit de
respecter l'emblème de la croix rouge
je vous remercie monsieur le président
en inde un an des élections législatives
anticipées auront lieu avant la fin du
mois de juillet prochain le parlement a
été dissous ce seront les troisièmes
élections en trois ans à moscou un
attentat détruit en partie l'hôtel in
touristes situé à 200 mètres du kremlin
des explosions spectaculaires aurait
fait plusieurs blessés
il pourrait s'agir d'un acte criminel ou
mafieux et puis à pékin c'est devant le
quartier général du régime chinois que
plus de dix mille personnes ont
manifesté hier pourtant ce genre de
défilé n'est guère toléré en chine les
manifestants étaient des adeptes d'une
secte
explications de notre correspondant à
pékin isabelle bechler avec tristan le
braz ces chinois appartiennent au plus
important des mouvements de tchi kong du
pays leur secteur revendique plus de 10
millions d'adeptes surtout dans le
nord-est particulièrement touché par la
crise
environ dix mille de ces bouddhistes ont
décidé de manifester pacifiquement car
50 des leurs ont été interpellés la
veille dans la ville portuaire de
tianjin
ils réclament la liberté de culte vous
pouvez pas parler
je suis content ce qui se passe mais je
ne peux rien vous dire avec autant de
monde autour
il faudrait qu'on soit seule la consigne
de silence de la secte est renforcée
encore par la présence massive mais
somme toute bienveillante de la police
le sit in durant aura plus de dix heures
près du siège du parti communiste
pendant qu'une délégation négociera avec
les autorités dans ce mouvement mystique
le falun gong mais dit on fait des
exercices physiques dérivés des arts
martiaux traditionnels
depuis 92 le gourou lironde je prêchais
écrivait et repoussait les affres de la
fin du monde
jusqu'au moment où il a choisi l'exil
pour aller savoir aux usa où son site
internet est elle à bord et
à un mois du 10e anniversaire de la
répression de tiananmen la contestation
vient d'où on ne l'attendait pas de ces
mouvements mystique qui n'ont même pas
pu s'enregistrer administrativement
comme des associations religieuses de
ces sectes dont certaines villes ont
interdit les pratiques physiques au
matin dans les parcs des mouvements qui
donne espoir mais s'appuie sur la
crédulité des moins éduqués et qui font
bien plus peur au gouvernement chinois
que les balbutiements d'un parti
démocratique en france en corse le
colonel commandant de la légion de
gendarmerie a été placé en garde à vue
dans le cadre d'une enquête policière
sur un incendie suspect d'une sorte de
période de plage près d'ajaccio
le colonel et deux autres gendarmes
gradés auraient été interpellées dans le
cadre d'une procédure de flagrant délit
beaucoup d'explications sont avancées
dont celle d'une nouvelle guerre des
polices entre guillemets commentaires
michele finn quelques ruines fumantes
voici tout ce qu'il reste de chez
francis l'un des restaurants les plus
cotés du golfe d'ajaccio
cette faille eux s'était installée en
toute illégalité sur le domaine public
maritime le presser bonnet avait ordonné
sa destruction
mais les marteaux piqueurs n'ont pas eu
le temps d'entrer en action dans la nuit
de lundi à mardi dernier un incendie
criminel détruites entièrement le
restaurant les gendarmes chargés de
l'enquêté découvre sur les lieux une
cagoule portant des traces de sang un
poste de radio
des bidons d'essence et ce tract
surprise la radio et la cagoule
appartiennent en fait à des gendarmes
plus précisément au gps le groupe de
pelotons de sécurité une unité d'élite
de la gendarmerie
créée en corse l'an dernier deuxième
surprise le commandant de cette unité le
capitaine en brosse et sérieusement
brûlé à la main et au visage
il est hospitalisé l'enquêté établira
que trois gendarmes se trouvaient en
fait sur les lieux
un lieutenant et un adjudant chef est le
capitaine selon leur version ils étaient
en mission de surveillance il se serait
enfui
craignant une embuscade problème les
trois gendarmes n'ont prévenu personne
du coup leurs explications n'ont pas
convaincu l'inspection technique de la
gendarmerie est chargée de l'enquêté
depuis samedi le lieutenant et
l'adjudant-chef sont en garde à vue le
colonel henry mazères patron de toute la
gendarmerie en corse est lui même gardé
à vue depuis cet après midi ce soir le
procureur de la république d'ajaccio
doit décidé l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire et d'éventuelles
mises en examen olivier théron sur place
face à ce qui est ce qu'on peut dire qui
est pas banal quand même avec se connaît
de gendarmerie quelles sont les
réactions ce soir d'abord une première
information c'est que la mise en examen
serait imminente et trois gendarmes sont
actuellement dans le cabinet du
procureur d'ajaccio alors sans doute
pour que leur soient signifiés la mise
en examen mais ça on verra plus tard
alors bien sûr cette affaire fait grand
bruit parce que le groupement le gps le
groupement est un groupe d'élite mise en
place l'été dernier un petit peu après
l'arrivée du préfet bonnet mais on sait
bien que les gendarmes sont des
militaires etc les militaires agissent
toujours dans le rouge s'explique mal
comment il aurait pu participer à
l'explosion qui a endommagé la paillote
et si leur participation dans l'attentât
de la paillote était démontrée par l'anc
est il faudrait bien sûr remonter la
piste du donneur d'ordre ici en corse
certains parlent déjà d'un rimbaud
warriors insulaires ou d'une affaire des
irlandais de vincennes bis en tout cas
sur l'île où l'action de l'état la
restauration de l'état de droit avec des
méthodes un peu musclées ne fait pas ne
fait pas fait assez peur il est assez
mal perçu cette affaire ne va
certainement pas apaisé les esprits
d'ailleurs le bâtonnier d'ajaccio
antoine sollacaro a demandé la démission
immédiate du préfet bonnet puisque les
gendarmes agissent généralement sous ses
ordres le préfet bonnet de son côté se
refuse à toute déclaration
il s'est borné à dire qu'il ne
commentait pas les faits divers une
déclaration qui a été très très mal
perçu bien sûr ici en corse
merci à lui à royan charente-maritime un
collège a été entièrement détruit dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche
comme le montrent ces images d'un
vidéaste amateur pas de blessé le
bâtiment était vide en effet il s'agit
d'un collège de type pailleron qui
accueillait 780 élèves
il a donc volé en deux heures à nice la
compagnie air france affirme ne poser
aucun préalable à la reprise des
discussions avec les personnels au sol
en grève depuis 11 jours il ya
d'ailleurs de lancement même une réunion
entre la direction et les syndicats mais
ce mouvement pourrait toucher marseille
où un préavis a été déposé par
solidarité il y à 13 ans le 26 avril
1986 c'était la catastrophe nucléaire de
tchernobyl un virus informatique qui se
déclenche le 26 de chaque mois et
baptisé virus tchernobyl il affecterait
plusieurs systèmes ordinateurs dans le
monde entier y compris aux etats-unis
c'est une menace bien réelle pour
l'informatique mondiale
l'explication patrice pollet il porte un
nom qui fait peur tchernobyl et son
oeuvre de destruction aurait déjà
commencé puisque aux états unis au
bangladesh plusieurs systèmes
informatiques seraient déjà en panne
d'après les spécialistes ce virus-là
serait l'un des plus méchant jamais
conçu son moyen de transport c'est le
réseau mondial internet et personne
n'est à l'abri il peut détruire des
fichiers il peut se mettre sur les
tables d'indexation des fichiers et par
conséquent il peut aussi bien modifier
des contenus de façon anormale que
modifier des fans fichiers ou des
ensembles d'obligations
ce virus est programmé pour s'attaquer
en priorité aux systèmes d'exploitation
windows 95 et 98
dans leurs démarches les créateurs de
virus ne manque pas d'idées
les objectifs sont variés il y en a qui
souhaitent simplement s'amuser on
appelle ça les créateurs ludique
il y en a qui veulent faire du mal vous
pouvez avoir des terroristes vous pouvez
avoir des brigands vous peut avoir
différentes catégories de personnes qui
veulent faire du mal il ya les gens qui
sont orientés business et qui font cela
pour que l'on n'ait plus confiance dans
le matériel et compte changer donc en
achètent d'autres
bref vous avez toutes sortes de
catégories de fabricants de virus et
toutes sortes de motivation pour se
débarrasser du virus se tient immobile
il va falloir trouver l'antidote
c'est à dire mettre au point le
programme informatique capable de
contrer toutes les actions néfastes de
ce destructeur à long travail qui peut
prendre des mois
en marge du football des émeus très
violentes ont eu lieu hier soir tard à
rotterdam alors que l'on fêtait un
beauty pour le club local de payer nord
les heurts ont opposé des hooligans sur
forces de police les dégâts matériels
sont considérables dans le centre de
rotterdam fin de 80 hooligans ont été
interpellés ces émeutes sont qualifié
d'inquiétant par les autorités
européennes du football car la
compétition de l'an 2000 l'euro 2000
doit avoir lieu aux pays-bas
alors maintenant du vrai football et du
beau football avec david ginola nicolas
anelka qui ont reçu d'un et l'autre les
trophées de meilleur joueur de l'année
en angleterre pourrait être cassé le
trophée de meilleur jeune joueur de
l'année
mais pour david ginola qui a permis à
tottenham de remporter la coupe de la
ligue
c'est une très belle récompense un an
après son absence de la coupe du monde
commentaire florent gautreau
c'est cantona qui va être jaloux ginola
ne le sait pas encore à cet instant mais
il s'apprête à recevoir le prix du
meilleur joueur de l'année en angleterre
une 12 consécration pour l'attaquant de
tottenham oublié en france
adulé outre-manche à 32 ans ginola ne
faiblit pas il marque il fait marquer il
vient de remporter la coupe de la ligue
anglaise
mais c'est dans la grisaille de
newcastle que l'enfant de sainte maxime
a entamé sa renaissance
quelques vues spectaculaires une
technique parfaite qui fait pâlir
d'envié n'importe quel joueur anglais au
nord de l'angleterre
on adore
ginola c'est aussi une image un produit
qui rapporte beaucoup
le royaume tout entier craque pour cette
gueule d'ange venus d'ailleurs
moi ce que je cherchais nuit et qu'il
est vraiment trop beau ce physique de
top model est pourtant à l'origine d'un
malentendu ginola défilent pour les
couturiers il fait de la publicité
il se fait plaisir mais il se fait du
tort on lui reproche d'oublier le
football il n'arrive pas à convaincre
aimé jacquet du contraire il ne jouera
pas la coupe du monde l'équipe de france
c'est le point noir de la carrière de
ginola les bleus ratent le mondial aux
états unis après la défaite contre la
bulgarie le peuple des stades
encouragés par un sélectionneur injuste
a trouvé son bouc émissaire c'est ginola
le choc qu'un joueur ait craqué à mon
avis à constituer
sûrement une goutte d'acide important
parce que la davie jean a commis un créé
une courte équipe j'aurais fait un crime
comptait quitter le mal-aimé du foot
français n'a plus rejoué avec les bleus
depuis quatre ans à la grande surprise
des anglais qui en ont fait leur dieu
vivant ginola a compris qu'il ne serait
jamais prophète en son pays
c'est un grand footballeur mais un
footballeur incompris
david ginola bonsoir bonsoir
alors c'est quoi c'est une revanche qui
vous fait sourire ou est ce que ça vous
fait toujours mal non non c'est celle à
la fin du petit sujet que vous venez de
passer un coup de bol rien compris non
je crois que je suis je suis compris
compris par mes pairs je crois que ça
c'est ce qui est le plus pour moi le
plus important
et puis j'ai entendu quelques paroles
désobligeantes qui me rappelle de vue
mauvais souvenir mais aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que je suis plongé dans une quelque
chose de très positif j'en suis je suis
très fier quelque part mais vous avez
quand même des regrets nous des regrets
on a toujours des regrets dans la vie
c'est vrai que ne pas avoir joué la
coupe du monde mais ça sera toujours un
regret mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je
peux pas revenir en arrière je peux pas
et réécrire le passé donc pour moi c'est
d'avoir gagné ce trophée c'est d'avoir
été élu meilleur joueur par mes pairs et
et pour moi ça veut dire beaucoup de
choses mais alors comment expliquez-vous
la voc des joueurs français en
angleterre vous maintenant adulé puis y
en aura d'autres qui en est le cas il ya
virage le plein comment vous expliquez
ça parce que le football français
aujourd'hui a démontré qu'il était un
football de qualité qu'au sein des
équipes françaises
il y avait des joueurs de talent que les
équipes anglaises qui ont énormément de
moyens financiers sont très très
intéressé par les joueurs français
parce qu'aujourd'hui le jeu français est
un petit peu
le jeu idéal pour pourri c'est en tout
cas ici à l'angleterre
bon alors est-ce que vous reviendrez
dans un grand club français ou italiens
ou espagnols que sais-je
écoutez je pense avoir avoir encore pas
mal de choses à faire ici en angleterre
donc je vais essayer de m'attacher à
faire encore de belles saisons ici à
l'honneur
vous aimez ou vous aimez pas quand on
vous dit gueule d'ange gueule d'ange je
suis fait un ange déjà gueule d'ange
kolda je vous savez je sais pas ça
dépend là la portée de cette phrase
gueule d'ange
non non c'est sympa ça fait plaisir mais
bon je préfère qu'on dise que je sois un
bon footballeur plutôt google d'un bon
et puis vous avez bon coeur de ce plan
vise à une action internationale on a
parlé récemment dans un journal
et puis je crois qu'avec d'autres
footballeurs avec le daily mail vous
avez fait une opération si pour le
kosovo oui ça c'est assez important on a
fait une opération avec le daily mail
qui est un journal presse quotidienne
ici en angleterre qui a vendu des dés
des maillots des casque de pilote de
formule 1 et qui a qui a essayé de
récupérer pas mal d'argent pour pour le
kosovo et on a récupéré 2 millions de
livres 2 millions et demi de livres
sterling qui fait à peu près 25 millions
de francs pour envoyer à la croix rouge
la croix rouge anglaise et la croix
rouge internationale pour aider les
réfugiés du kosovo donc ça c'est quelque
chose qu'il fallait signaler parce que
c'est aussi très positif merci beaucoup
david ginola puis bravo et merci à y
voir de plus en plus souvent merci
beaucoup mais nous arrivons à la fin de
ce journal je rappelle deux informations
que nous avons développées tout d'abord
concernant les réfugiés albanais du
kosovo qui traverse le monténégro pour
rejoindre l'albanie de président
albanais souhaite le maintien de
l'action de l'otan et que le temps a
jusqu'au bout monsieur somaro garde
président du comique intense hier de la
croix-rouge internationale a rencontré
ce run and poor's et fitch
la croix rousse seraient bien autorisé à
pénétrer au kosovo pour une action
humanitaire
et puis en corse un colonel de
gendarmerie placé en garde vis avec deux
autres gradés de la gendarmerie
ils pourraient être les sites à mettre
au conditionnel mis en examen dans les
heures qui viennent après l incendie
suspect d'une paillote sur une plage
près d'ajaccio
dans quelques secondes la météo avec
sophie davant et puis la deuxième et
dernière partie deux premiers de cordée
le téléfilm adapté de l'oeuvre de frison
roche à 22h35 vous retrouver paul amar
pour d'un monde à l'autre et puis à 0
heures 20 le dernier journal ne sera
présenté par florence duprat suivi du
cercle de philippe lefait avec pour
thème le maroc demain vous retrouverez à
13h rachid arhab là demain 20h bonsoir
merci
tous